[Music]
who did the Bills beat in the Wild Card
round that year to advance to the
division the New England Patriots yes
who did the Chiefs beat in the Wild Card
round that year I don't know Steelers
which quarterback finished with more
passing yards Josh Allen mahes Mahomes
oh that's
cool which quarterback finished with the
better passer rating
Ms feel like I peed a little how many
times did the lead change in the final
minute 54 regulation four two four what
was the Bill's record going into this 12
and six and what was the Chiefs record
going into this game 13 and
four 13 how long was Harrison butto his
field goal As Time expired to send the
game to overtime 49 49 D let's go Brian